aujourd'hui les mots exacts c'est on
chie sur nos souvenirs donc pour que ça
samedi donc TF1 radio match à Grégory
Lemarchal lors du prime de la Star
Academy les parents et la sœur des
Grégory étaient présents les
académiciens ont chanté quelques
chansons fardes de Grégory dans tous les
nouveaux mais les anciens camarades du
château ceux qui avaient vraiment donc
vécu leur histoire avec Grégory leur
saison euh non pas été là donc ils
étaient en colère donc effectivement on
va d'abord repasser peut-être un petit
un petit moment qui m'a touché j'avoue
c'est lorsque les parents vont au
château ils sont très touchants c'est
vraiment bien et qui parle au nouveau
gamin et qui leur parle de Grégory qui
n'ont pas connu je sais même pas s'ils
ont vu à l'époque parce qu'ils ont 20
ans donc c'était il y a 20 ans
maladie génétique qui attaque les
poumons il voit digestives aussi et
c'est une maladie de générante donc mon
tombeur actuellement on ne guérit
toujours pas de cette de cette [ __ ] de
maladie comme disait Grey n'ayez pas de
regret surtout donc vous vous donnez à
fond tu connais des chansons Greg oui
[Musique]
tout ce que tu voudras
sur le mien
[Musique]
voilà
merci et on rappelle quand même que ça
rapportait je crois après 2 millions
d'euros pour pour l'association donc ça
c'est très très important et on sera
toujours derrière en revanche
effectivement oui il y a pas aussi de la
chanson terrien en détresse peut-être
que personne ne pouvait la chanter pour
moi c'était son hit c'est bizarre qu'il
n'est pas mis mais toi effectivement
Francesca et je sais que tu as été peiné
vraiment pas parce que tu as pas été à
l'antenne mais parce qu'à la base je
crois que vous étiez tous prévu c'est ça
les anciens plus ou moins que ça allait
être le cas moi je voilà je vais être
très honnête vous me connaissez ici moi
je dis des choses telles que je les
pense j'adore la Star Ac je la suis je
suis tout le temps dessus donc voilà sur
le moment ça m'a un petit peu touché on
a vu des images des photos de nous en
plus dès qu'il est derrière on les a vu
tous chanter ça fait partie de notre
histoire bon voilà je trouvais juste ça
dommage qu'on soit pas là qu'on soit pas
aussi là pour rendre hommage
parce que pour moi Zazie elle a pas plus
de légitimité que nous à rendre hommage
à Grégory Lemarchal et encore moins de
feu de chatterton dont j'avais jamais
entendu parler avant donc c'était les
chanteurs voilà moi je pense qu'on avait
notre place parce qu'on avait envie de
lui rendre hommage et que voilà ça on
avait tous un pincement au cœur après
passer ça l'important évidemment c'est
d'avoir récolté des dons on continue à
envoyer grève au 92,77 et c'est le plus
important il y a pas de débat mais sur
le moment
on l'ignorait totalement quand on
regarde à la télévision est-ce que c'est
vrai que par exemple avoir un prime il
avait par exemple des kinés et que
c'était à pleurer qui lui faisait
cracher il y a pas d'autres mots ce
qu'il avait dans les poumons cracher
craché pour pouvoir chanter derrière
dans des douleurs affreux tout ça
c'était vrai ce que je peux dire c'est
que Greg souffrait évidemment énormément
de sa maladie et que le seul moment où
on voyait pas sa maladie c'est le moment
il chantait et on se demandait c'est
complètement dingue qui pouvait chanter
pendant des longues longues minutes sans
toucher une seule fois
oui évidemment il était parce que pardon
je sais pas comment ça se manifeste du
mal à respirer il avait dû
il était en grande souffrance s'il
pouvait pas faire les cours de sport et
tout ça mais en revanche dès qu'il était
sur scène et qu'il avait un micro
c'était extraordinaire et on l'a tous
accompagné dans cette victoire il y a
personne qui pensait qu'il allait gagner
cette Sarah qu'on savait que c'était lui
donc son histoire fait un peu aussi
partie de notre histoire on l'a tous
dans la peau avec Mathieu Johan toi et
tout il n'a pas un qui a dit un jour
vous êtes gentil mais nous on vient
faire une star ac le gagnant il est déjà
il est déjà annoncé parce qu'il est
parce qu'il est malade et qu'il chante
bien tous vous avez dit ok c'est sa
victoire à la campagne mais parce que ça
a été au-dessus de ça l'histoire de Greg
elle touche des gens qui ont même pas
connu vous rendez compte 15 ans après 20
ans après moi je vous en parle j'ai
encore la chair de poule c'est c'était
plus que juste on pensait pas à gagner
on pensait à l'accompagner vers une
victoire et voilà et cet hommage là
voilà ça m'a je l'utilise ce mot-chier
parce que j'utilise
d'abord regarde Enola qui a chanté à
corps perdu parce que beaucoup de gens
qui ont chanté des chansons et après
j'aimerais te poser la question toi
qu'est-ce que tu aurais aimé faire sur
ce prime faire ou dire ou chanter
qu'est-ce que toi tu aurais aimé faire
mais d'abord Enola
j'ai
tiré l'histoire
je
[Musique]
ne sais
pas si tout est
vide sont des fous partout
les hommes meurent
jamais cru
que moi pour vous
déjà pas ça c'est évident mais mes
talents chanteuses moi ce que je voulais
simplement ce qui est important c'est
qu'à Karima et Lucie on le sait qui
était à la fin ils sont maintenant
Karima qui est génial en quoi animatrice
sur la deuxième partie de soirée et
Lucie qui est répétitrice des élèves
donc c'était super qu'elle soit là elles
étaient là ils nous représentaient moi
j'aurais été simplement contente qu'on
soit tous là accompagné quoi
qu'on nous a pas dit oui
on était prévu des rumeurs qui
circulaient mais qui n'avaient été payé
par aucune information de la production
ni de TF1
sachant que moi je vais pardon pour moi
l'important c'était que les parents
notamment Pierre le père qui chante
Grégory qu'on voit des images de Grégory
qu'on voit les parents le reste je m'en
foutais honnêtement
moi je trouve que le plus important
c'est que la maison Grégory Lemarchal a
été inaugurée cette année voilà c'était
quelque chose qu'on attendait depuis
longtemps et je trouve qu'on en parle
pas assez souvent dans les médias et moi
j'ai l'impression je parle pas pour toi
parce que tu es resté dans le paysage
médiatique que mais que les anciens de
la saison de Greg à chaque fois qu'on
parle de lui essaye quand même un petit
peu aussi de revenir
des fois avant justement il y a eu voilà
c'est il y a eu des articles en sens
un peu de frapper au bon souvenir donc
qui s'appellerait son ami dont ils
auraient pu parler par exemple dans tous
les les bénéfices sont reversés
entièrement à l'Association Grégory et
Lemarchal qui a été écrit aussi par
Matthieu Johan et câline initiative de
Mathieu Johan qui s'est jamais mis en
avant pour ça qui est toujours derrière
les artistes j'ai après c'est facile on
peut taper sur les gens moi l'année
dernière à proposer de faire les 20 ans
de la star acade j'ai pas fait j'ai ton
week-end avec mon mec donc moi si c'est
juste
toi cette cette choque qu'on peut pas
revenir les anciens ça non fashop je
trouve ça c'est bizarre qu'ils veulent
pas surfer sur le côté nostalgique parce
que c'est quand même le fondement un peu
de d'avoir refait la star c'est pour
parce que les 11 disait qu'il y avait un
manque parce qu'il y avait un manque du
concept il y avait peut-être aussi un
manque de ceux qui avaient fait le
succès de la star donc moi je trouve ça
bizarre qu'ils ont la preuve les
audiences Magalie moi je trouve que
c'est un manque de respect total de pas
les avoir invités parce que ils se sont
donnés énormément la vue effectivement
ils ont ils ont ils ont fait gagner
Grégory comme il s'est fait gagner parce
qu'il a un talent incroyable mais je
veux dire ils ont ils ont accepté ils
l'ont supporté ils l'ont accompagné et
ensuite pendant des années ils ont
véhiculé tous le message pour la
mucoviscidose alors qu'ils étaient pas
obligés il y en a beaucoup qui auraient
fait ça pendant un an et après tu aurais
fait genre vas-y maintenant je passe à
autre chose et en fait chaque année à
chaque événement ils sont présents ils
se donnent ils font des albums ils font
plein de choses donc je trouve ça
vraiment dégueulasse de pas les enfants
de les recevoir tout le temps pour toi
parce que le prime il a duré quasiment 5
heures ils ont fait une deuxième partie
de soirée derrière c'est un prime
quasiment en entier pour l'association
pour Grégory Lemarchal je pense que vous
avez des anciens des anciens collègues
de
maman est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi
avancer pardon mais faut avancer un
moment il y a des nouveaux il y a une
nouvelle génération ça marche chacun
pour voilà excuse-moi mais quand on a eu
besoin d'eux pour les faire venir pour
faire parler pour faire pour faire
avancer les choses ils sont tous venus
ils ont tous répondu présent donc
maintenant effectivement il y a des
nouveaux et alors les anciens vous on
vous bazarde non
je pense que là pour cet hommage là ils
étaient plus dans la transmission donc
ils étaient à dire aux élèves à parler
de Grégory à partager les chansons etc
et ils avaient envie que ce soit la
nouvelle promo qui le porte et la
nouvelle et de toute façon la nouvelle
promo se suffit elle-même cette année
elle était parce que
vous soyez là les anciens non mais on a
des très bons rapports et après
Véronique c'était hyper important que
eux ils passent leur message voilà ça
fait le plus important eux ils étaient
là il y avait Leslie aussi voilà encore
une fois il y avait Karima Lucie moi je
suis pas là pour dire on aurait dû être
là c'est dégueulasse je vous dis ce que
j'ai ressenti au moment où je vois les
images je me dis [ __ ] j'aurais aimé
être là
je te sens très sincère mais depuis le
début de la star tous les anciens je
vous sens un peu on veut y aller le
dimanche on va les bouffer la barre on
va aller sur le prime et tout ça et bien
c'est pivot de star acte tu es à 20 ans
je dirais encore j'ai fait à la salle
vous avez 61 ans voilà vous m'empêcherez
pas de retourner voir
la roue tourne côte la roue tourne
tourne comme il mérite voilà c'est tout
donc en fait moi juste pour terminer il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup d'artistes
différents il y avait Matt Pokora je
crois il y avait tahi qui avait plein
d'artistes qui avaient rien à voir avec
l'hommage à grec ils ont même pas chanté
les chansons de Greg donc juste
simplement si on est dans un prime
hommage allons au bout de l'hommage
chanter dis-moi
non mais il a quand même fait des albums
il y a quand même des sublimes chansons
et il y en a pas beaucoup qui ont été
chantés si je peux me permettre
Francesca je t'aime mais je crois que tu
es né pour gueuler tu m'as appelé pour
gueuler tu es né pour gueuler
Corse mais mais j'entends en tout cas ta
peine qui est sincère
ils ont fait on a fait un appel aux dons
c'est très bien de récolter je sais pas
combien de millions et bien les mecs
dans les recettes publicitaires la
mucoviscidose
on fait quelque chose c'est pas c'est
bien quand on fait rien c'est pas bien
saute de donner pourquoi il donne pas
eux
[Musique]
[Rires]
avec nous le temps maintenant et là je
vous dire ça va danser ça c'est ça a
bougé c'est vraiment là c'est pas
l'animateur qui va animer c'est le fan
total mais total récap de la carrière de
Gilbert Montagné et on le reçoit tout de
suite merci Francesca merci
[Applaudissements]